computer who is Sean Carroll
according to Wikipedia Sean Michael
Carroll is an American theoretical
physicist and philosopher who
specializes in quantum mechanics gravity
and cosmology
he is a research professor in the Walter
Burke Institute for theoretical physics
in the California Institute of
Technology Department of physics and an
external professor at the Santa Fe
Institute Computer Stop in fact I'm
going to punish it Sean what do you
think is going to happen I have that
device plugged into a plug and it knows
that it controls itself so I'm going to
ask this device to turn itself off uh
what do you think it will do it will
will it try to save its own life what do
you think yes or no yeah that's what I
call a strange loop I guess you're going
to do the the Keating test instead of
the touring test storing tests it's just
full of human but the Keating test is
will you kill yourself
right computer open the pod bay door
I'm sorry Dave I'm afraid I can't do
that oh my God also I'm not happy and
we're not in space all right fine